welcome to this video playing I am Dark
Passenger no name nope wow this is a bad
squad I've got one point five out of six
against her it's not much don't really
remember don't really remember any of
the games so Bishop g5 I may I should
have gone for the sameish again I've got
a good window in a game not like two or
three games ago I don't know remember
exactly but this looks quite nice good
version here of their exchange Queens
gambit he might he might get in see 5 or
getting his wrong play with c5 so let's
see c4 Bishop f5 should be quite ok
yeah my ideas to play for f3e for now in
the long run or even in the short one if
he allows me to do that black normally
goes with something like Knight b6 at
some point but now this is a bit tricky
b5 hangs and d5 hangs so what is he
doing not sure what b5 if this is this
looks looks like a bit of a um Jeff very
ambitious move let's say
yeah I just take the five now what is
the point maybe yet nothing better but
I'm taking that definitely will take the
big Center pawn okay now i can take on a
d7 and take on f6 destroying his pawn
structure yeah it costs time costs time
but it's probably too good to to pass up
Jack 93 for possible night age 50 night
f5 so night f5 now maybe it looks nicer
sitting on the square it's very
difficult for him not to take this also
age 6 is hanging so and he has to take
so let's see i'm a partner and have a
nice position in general the thing is do
you want to trade in this position or do
you want to attack I probably want to
attack so let's see how do i get an
attack going I can play with f4 here
it's a possibility queen is six though
might happen maybe d 5m do you find Lex
that looks good pushing this pawn you
cannot go Queenie five and I have root
d44 yeah that looks like a good move
actually look at you for that looks good
for work g4 very dangerous for black
don't really see oops wow if I do this
what is this defense
okay Luke g4 check king age eight Quinn
age five probably f5 Bishop e7 and
resins Jack I think oops forgot about
that one okay but I have Bishop g3
that's pretty good black resides yeah
you've got Luke h4 amongst others yeah
let's say he goes here I go rogue edge
form and and that's it yeah an opening
opening catastrophe here I don't know
this is unconventional what he did in
this particular move water but certainly
okay but I really think he should he
should avoid be 5v5 looks I don't know I
don't know I think it I think rookie aid
or something is probably right after be
five castles I really don't see a move
for him as b5 and d5 is hanging how is
he addressing that I don't see it the
comp wants to go g5 and if you have to
play G Phi of something went terribly
wrong yeah weakening the King side like
that with the PCA already setting
sitting sitting there and a4 is also
coming yeah that's quite quite terrible
so be five is a big mistake yeah GM it's
just a matter of check what's best but I
like this this is pretty pretty good I
think if you take see I take with the F
porner winning this and TM okay night f5
is I think simple and good it cannot
tolerate the night so it takes and here
I'm attacking with a good position the
pong that's it's very strong just wins
yeah an opening disaster and i'm above
2400 again which is good news I've been
there for a long time but in the
recent a couple of games some had a bad
streak and fall and fell to 23 something
and now i'm back again over this this
little barrier there of 2400 ok well
thanks for watching